i like to travel a lot less than i did i
was much easier traveling than than now
like i don't want to be away from my
kids
as i was leaving to come here this week
my four-year-old son
turns to me and he goes don't go to
nashville dad don't go to nashville
and i was like that is the that is the
saddest thing i i i like it
it tears your heart out you're like why
are you doing this i i did inform him
he's like how am i gonna know when
you're back it's like well
because i was coming back late at night
i'm coming back late at night and he
says how do you how do i know
then you're gonna be back so i'm gonna
come in your room i'm gonna take pants
out of your door and put them on your
head
and he said that's so cute and he said
okay so tonight
ben the dad we don't get this at the
bend this is actually great
[Music]
do your best to give a summary of the
history of candace owens and ben shapiro
the actual history is that thank god
i've had a really
well when i say privileged life i don't
mean privilege in terms of economics i
grew up in a house with
three younger sisters and all four of us
shared one bedroom and a two bedroom
house with one bathroom
until i was 11. so uh it really isn't uh
it really is a privilege that way i'm
privileged because i have an
amazing set of parents i have a two
parent family uh
i have great siblings um i grew up in a
really solid community that
shared i think a really great set of
values i was able to go to good schools
and i was able to have excellent
teachers
uh and my parents made sure that i
learned from as many people as humanly
possible they opened a lot of doors for
me to be able to
uh to experience different ideas uh and
you know because of that and because i'm
i'm i tend to be
pretty hungry for knowledge uh i spent
an enormous amount of time
outside in in and outside of school
reading educating myself becoming good
at what it is that i do and i spent a
lot of years perfecting that i mean i've
been writing a syndicated column since i
was 17 years old i'm now 37 years old
i've been doing this for 20 years
uh and uh and you know you try enough
things and you fail at enough things and
eventually you get good at things and
and i think that's the story of this
company uh i think that's the story of
sort of my career i think most and the
most important thing about me
personally is that i happen to be a
fantastic father and a fantastic husband
they're really those are those are the
two most important things about me and i
say that with
with all due humility but actually i'm
really like of the things in my life
that i'm good at i am the best at being
a father and i'm the best of being a
husband i'm excellent at it that's right
and i take great pride in that
i love that because i think family is
the most important thing like it really
is like none of it means anything if you
don't have your family
um if you don't have your family in
order if you have your house in order
and i think that that's kind of one of
the things that we really get right as
conservatives and the left really gets
wrong with them trying to strip down
the family because it all starts from
there if that's i mean if that's if
that's not right nothing in your life
can really be right um
i guess i don't my story is very i guess
very opposite
in that i came from nothing i had a very
disruptive
household growing up but i was very
fortunate to have my grandparents
and when they saw what we were living in
which was
you know a roach infested apartment me
and my two sisters shared a bedroom my
grandfather just said i don't want my
grand babies to grow up like that
because i worked too hard for them to
grow up like that
he grew up on a sharecropping farm grew
up in the segregated south
never ever heard from his mouth growing
up in his household i moved into his
house when i was nine
um he's never ordered a one bad sentence
about a white person
and so it was sort of that quiet
knowledge um
he never ever said anything against
white people and i think
just being able to sit around the
breakfast table with him every morning
he was you know all about reading the
bible we had to
we had prayers we had to study from the
bible every single morning as he'd make
us this big southern breakfast like that
is what shaped candace owens that is the
cannatone story
and it was happening subliminally i mean
i did i never
never meant politics to me i just knew
my parents got something wrong
my grandparents got something right and
that's ironic because
we're supposed to believe that the way
my grandfather suffered is why we're
dealing with all the stuff now
my father obviously grew up in a later
time and yet he got something wrong and
my grandfather got something right
growing up in the 40s
married at 17 never you know divorced my
grandmother uh you know stayed with her
until her
dying day in 2013. so you know my story
is my grandfather's story and i think my
perspective of the world is informed by
how could i as a black american complain
when my grandfather never did and his
first job was when he was five
you know laying tobacco out to dry on a
sharecropping farm it's
i'm insulted by black americans that
complained today
um i'm genuinely insulted by i think we
do our
ancestors the greatest disservice the
ones who worked hard
so that we could have these
opportunities um to walk into any room
and to not
say look me i'm a black person and so i
deserve this
um so the people that worked you know
didn't live through a day of strife are
the ones with all the complaints
and my granddad was just sort of a
no-nonsense you're going to work every
day
um kind of guy and he's he still remains
the greatest blessing and
the biggest influence in my life out of
the two of you
which one trends on twitter more often i
think i tread i trend more violently if
that makes any more sense i was gonna
i kind of think that's true yeah i kind
of think that's true although right now
it seems like there is this sort of ping
pong effect where
you trend and then i defend you and i
trend right or vice versa or vice versa
yeah so it's good we've created a sort
of
twitter dynamic here right but i think
if you went back he's probably trended
more but when i trend it it will last
for 72 hours i think that's right yeah
when you guys find out that you're
trending what is the process from there
do you stop and look at everything
or you just a normal part of your day
always late we both always find out like
12 hours after the trend has started
yeah so i tend to trend
disproportionately on sabbath so i don't
find out until
after sabbath is over i'm like wow
that's i had a good day so i don't
really care but it actually it used to
bother me like two three years ago it
used to bother me
and i actually did remove twitter from
my phone so i don't actually have
twitter on my phone specifically because
i don't want to know
and i figure i have enough people who
work at this company that if something
is really bad they'll let me know
and it's never anything bad it's always
something dumb that media matters took
out of context and that makes perfect
sense in context
and it trends for no reason right
exactly i feel the same way i feel like
it's usually something really stupid
and when i look at it i'm like what am i
even trending over and as of recently
it's been extra stupid because it's
surrounding cardi b
when was the first time that you both
heard about the other
i knew about ben i know the first time i
started watching his videos
um when i started working for turning
point usa when charlie kirk
first reached out to me and wanted me to
work for turning point
he said every single day you need to
train to debate because
they will try to kill you before you can
even become big and he gave me
a video of ben shapiro on stage with
black lives matter
and it's an epic video by the way i
think it's like one of the best videos
like completely by himself and there's
like three woke black lives matter
activists and he
shuts the entire room up including them
by asking them
uh you know just about their entire
ideology i mean i can't even do it like
i would do a complete
i'd like to see if you should have a spa
because it's pretty amazing but i think
he was just fired up and they all just
get quiet talking about black on black
crime and black culture and
it's pretty beautiful so i believe the
first time
i heard of you is when you were working
with charlie right um but
you know i'd obviously that's the first
time that
i i know i'd come across your name
before uh and i'm sure it was because
of one of the viral videos that you had
made talking about race in america
and saying things that no one else will
say and i was like every other
conservative going
who is this and how does she have the
bravery to say that so that was that was
a new one
yeah which one of you would win in a
debate
what are we debating hmm
that's a good question that is a good
question it's a good question i feel
like there are certain subjects
definitely going to be some topics that
ben's going to be like
you know he could probably hand me my
ass and there's definitely going to be
some topics that i think i could hand
him
his ass on i think that's fair yeah
how should people respond to the cancel
mob um
i mean
[Laughter]
pretty much me if you don't if you start
apologizing to the left you'll never
stop apologizing so don't apologize
ever for anything to them because for
them it's not about them
actually wanting an apology it's what
they actually want is submission they
just want to see you submit
and you should never submit to somebody
that's just looking for dominance
never show your neck to somebody who's
seeking to chop off your head yup
can political conservatives ever be
cancelled or is it just people who come
out as conservatives
well i mean listen i think there are
certain rules that if you violate them
it's a problem i'm not going to pretend
there are no rules in the public
discourse there are certain people who
say things that are so wildly out of
bounds that
it's very difficult to defend the things
that they say um but
uh i will say that typically speaking
you can only be canceled by your own
side
uh it's it's people who come out as
conservatives who are in real
danger because those people have not yet
established a base inside
conservative movements uh so if you are
working in hollywood and you're not
openly conservative you can be canceled
because the people who surround you are
not people
who you can trust but if you're you or
if you're me and in that way
we're safer than a lot of the people who
are you know in hollywood and who are
living undercover
right for us we get to say what we want
for a living yeah and
if the left comes after us so what we
have a huge base of people who support
us and love us and and back what we do
but
i'm not going to pretend that it's easy
for people who are out there there are a
lot of people in
kind of the conservative side who say
well you know no matter what your job
you should stand up and you should speak
out right now a lot of those people have
families to support and have a lot of
sympathy for them yeah i totally agree
and that's actually
that's a really solid point like you're
more at risk if you're lying about who
you are
because if you're already out and you
are who you are then it's like all right
well you're amongst friends and really
it would take a mob of conservatives to
be upset
with something that i did to really
cancel me because i obviously the left's
not going to take you
you don't want to be on the left and the
conservatives won't have you so i think
that you kind of nailed that answer
what is something that you're most proud
of in your career
yeah what have you been ben i mean i
mean
i mean honestly for me it's the number
of is the number of people who i get
letters from who say that they
have not just switched their their
political viewpoint which is nice uh but
they've actually changed how they live
their lives i get a lot of these kinds
of letters from people thank god it
means that uh you know when they listen
to the show they're getting something
more than just the politics from it and
people who say that they
felt like their their life was on the
wrong track you know they i've gotten
letters from women who said that they've
not had abortions because they've
listened to show wow or men who've said
that they've
uh were thinking about breaking up with
a girlfriend who was pregnant and said
they got together and they got married
and he got a job
i've got a lot of those kind of letters
people who have decided that they were
going to
get a job and i got one letter from a
guy who said that when he started
listening to the show he was homeless
and then he decided he was going to
uh somehow enroll himself in college and
go to law school he ended up at i
believe at harvard law school
according to him yeah those kind of
stories are pretty amazing it does show
that politics has outsized influence
especially when you're
discussing things that aren't just
politics but deeper values underlying
politics
yeah i would say two things that i'm
proud of the first is that i never
compromised who i was
and um i think that that's really hard
uh well you know when you're in the
political space because there's a lot of
temptation to compromise who you are
and people telling you what you have to
be and i think i've stood firm on that
but then secondly which is more
in line with what we are saying is
nothing makes my heart
um feel bigger than when a black person
comes up to me and says
i feel like you gave me my life back and
it's such a heavy compliment because i
know exactly what they're saying
black people in particular don't even
it's like running around and not
realizing that you're in prison
you know and and then suddenly somebody
says to you i mean i really i always say
it's like
the allegory of the cave you know what i
mean you don't even know that you're
living in this cave you have no idea
these are shadows on the wall and it's
not reality and then suddenly
somebody goes oh wait here's all of this
the entire world outside and you can see
for the first time
and when so when they say that to me
when they say candace i feel like you're
giving my life back that's how i felt i
felt like thomas soul gave me my life
back
i didn't even know that my life was
taken away so that compliment always
hits me the hardest um because i just
i've been there before
what is something about you that you
think each other would be surprised to
know
i think i'm probably nerdier than people
probably have me pegged like
me my husband it's weird i think people
don't
think i'm as much of a bookworm as i am
i'm very much into books and i think
when i first hit the scene probably so
many people were like oh she's just
doing the like
cute servative thing you know what i
mean i'm like no no no like i'm
i actually love to read i've always been
a bit of a dweeb and english was always
my favorite subject so i love like the
greats
plato aristotle like all that stuff and
i think that that probably doesn't
read when i'm like smacking down celebs
on twitter
yeah i mean for me obviously it's that
i'm a platinum award winning
rap artist if you just looked at me you
wouldn't know that but
but the truth is that i do do a version
of whap that absolutely slap
a trend it does okay here's the thing
you wouldn't be that bad of a rapper
because you speak fast
oh yeah and if you talk fast you you all
you need is a little bit of flow and
some rhymes you probably would actually
kill it
i will never try that that sounds
amazingly terrible
you never know it'll just be a mystery
wrapped in enigma forever
what is your least favorite part of
being a political commentator
oh i 100 would say
it is the exposure unnecessarily that my
family has to it
meaning that like it's very difficult i
think for my sisters when they go online
and people are debating
me so it's like i don't care whatever i
have to receive but it always sucks when
people that i care about who have
nothing to do with this lifestyle
suddenly have to
answer for statements that i've said and
things that i believe in so i think
that's probably
that's definitely a good answer i it for
me it was probably the security that has
been attendant around everything
uh so it went from being i could walk
around anywhere without any security to
my wife having to get used to security
my kids having to get used to security
now they think it's natural because
they've had it since they're very small
um but
it's at the beginning it was it was a
bit of a culture shock for them
unfortunately it's it's a nasty world
out there and you know
it twitter is just a terrible place it's
just a terrible place filled with
horrible people it is hell on earth so
naturally it's where we make
a good deal of our money so right i
totally agree i totally agree family
uh you're both stranded on a desert
island separately
how was cardi b what are three things
you'd want to have with you
a family yeah exactly i mean it can't be
people so
um things are people yeah yeah
and i assume there's enough food right
because otherwise this is a real short
stay
so um well yeah if there's food because
let me just be frank about this in an
apocalypse i'm the first one to go
right like my skill set just does not
apply in an apocalypse
right if there's a zombie apocalypse
like i can't do plumbing
i'm not like i'm not a great shot like
i'm
like i can i can talk to the zombies but
i feel like it won't be super convincing
like so my skill might yeah my skill set
just
does not meet with the with the approval
of pre-civilization
so is it so yeah i mean but
if if the question is what can i bring
with me uh copy of the
complete uh tanakh which would be the uh
the old testament the prophets and the
writings
um the uh complete works of shakespeare
and uh the complete audio playlist of
probably beethoven guys he just took all
all books well beethoven i guess the
audio playlist
music's a good one music is a good one
gosh i don't know what i would take
that's really hard for me
i don't know i i mean i definitely would
take a bible
but it would be one object i don't know
about the other two if i can't take
people i don't i don't really know i
mean i feel like i don't have that much
of an attachment to anything that's
on this earth that i'd be like i must
take this without me it would always it
would always be people you know it would
be my husband
i'm actually by the way if you're trying
to survive i'm pretty i can cut a pipe
my dad was a plumber so i'm i'm oh no
you i have no question i'm good
here's the thing you need to take pick
me so number one you're gonna be 100
more useful than i am but that's true of
every single person who's in this room
in this building and probably in this
city
right like i'm a trained lawyer okay
like i'm the person that they kill for
food first like an accountable zombie
you might get it together
and you're an accountable situation my
only saving grace is that i am not a
large person
right because i would be certainly the
first to be sacrificed without a doubt
yeah i feel like we have to get you like
remember the survivor on an island
that would be some really good reality
tv survivor with like
ben on an island i i feel like i feel
like naked and alone i'm toast right
survivor i'd be okay yeah oh yeah i
could manipulate my way out of that yeah
come on like that's that's i love that
yeah convincing that's all you really
need to be exact right
you don't have to be good at anything
yeah survivor you just have to be
convincing and then i feel like
i could i could handle myself but if it
involves like starting a fire
killing an animal yeah like no this is
where's the supermarket
yeah are there matches yeah this makes
no sense no
how will conservatives know when we're
making progress in the culture war
i think we are now i think the fact that
we were just asked
you know how do you respond to all the
times you're trending i mean the only
reason we're trending is because the
left is threatened by us
um and we're able to drum up enough
conversation
regarding what we've said or you know
regarding what we're doing and i think
that that
is one of the good things about daily
wire is they understand that there is
this
this huge hole this vacuous space right
now being created
by the cancel culture um where
eventually daily wire could be the new
nbc abc because
you know cancer culture is a cancer and
it will eventually eat itself
and something else will have to pop up
in its place
um so i think conservatives get that and
we're kind of
kind of out there doing what we have to
do i mean candace's rise in the cultural
space is really
an excellent indicator as to as to where
we are i mean the fact is that people
who are
you know most respected and most
successful members of the culture are
responding directly to things that
candace is saying
because they are concerned that
conservatives might be making inroads
in this particular space and you know i
think that they are going to
the left is just going to continue to
provide the right with opportunities by
taking popular things
and destroying them because they have to
destroy everything that is good and
decent about the country right now
including all of its fundamental
institutions the more they continue to
destroy that stuff the more ground
they're going to open up for us
i mean they can continue to do this but
they should understand that they are
alienating a huge number of americans
and there are those of us out there who
are entrepreneurial enough to fill that
space and provide alternatives yep
what do your spouses love or hate about
what you do
my husband hates that social media is a
part of what i have to do because it's
such a time suck i hate it too though so
we agree on that front it's just like i
have to do a video and respond and do
all this because you kind of
you have to be engaged in social media
at least i do in a way
um that's meaningful um
what do you i mean he loves everything i
do my husband's my biggest fan so
um he's always amazed at things that i'm
doing and we're just such a great
partnership i mean he
is truly the business mind i'm the
creative mind and it just works
so so number one how long have you been
married i have been married for
i should just under two years yeah so he
loves what you do now
um i've married for almost 13 years so
like a long time uh and you know
it starts off with a lot of enthusiasm
candace and over time
over time certain things become more
irksome yeah
like what uh into my future yeah it
mostly just
it's always the time suck and because i
mean now you have a kid so as
as you have more kids and as the family
becomes bigger and the time demands
become larger
it's not just i need to take off time to
do a video it's like
you don't have time to go to the
bathroom right you don't have time to do
anything like all time is just gone
and the demands on the time are
extraordinary and so it used to be that
my wife was deeply concerned with
what happened during the week and you
know on a normal day we'd sort of sit
down and discuss what had happened
at my work during the week and now it's
like we look at each other it's 9 30 at
night the kids have finally gone to bed
they're going to wake me up at five
o'clock in the morning and we look at
each other and we're like
okay we can spend some time and talk
about our lives or
we can just collapse and most nights
you end up just collapsing and so that
means that at the end of the week she'll
say like well how was your week because
i don't even remember the beginning of
this week
right so the thing that the thing that
she she hates the most about
my career is that it takes time away
from you know all the stuff that
actually matters all the family kind of
stuff
uh and the thing i do love the most
about my wife is that she does not give
a damn what i do i mean she really does
not care she she doesn't she
like she finds it interesting and she
follows it sort of
um but she she could not care less
what who we are meeting i think we've
you know met
every important politician in the
country she does not care right uh we've
met a bunch of celebrities she does not
care
it's so charming it's so wonderful i i
have so many great stories of her
meeting people who are extremely famous
and having no clue who they are
and it's one of the most charming things
about her it's also how i know that she
she loves me for me number one because
anyone who marries me would have to love
me for me because there really is
nothing else to offer
but beyond that um she uh we we met when
she was 20 and i was 23. uh and
uh and so how did you meet where'd you
meet uh my sister fixed us up she was at
ucla
at the time and i just graduated harvard
law and i uh i came back
and my sister said there's this really
beautiful girl who's going to ucla
and i think you're really going to like
her i said it sounds great but she's
dating somebody else
well i can't do that so just waiting you
know and then about six months later
it's like whatever happened to that girl
she's like well i think she's single now
and i was like okay great and so we met
uh our first date was september 5th
i proposed on december 20
december 15th she accepted the same year
oh yeah she accepted it on december 22nd
so we did it for about three months wow
and uh two weeks
from meeting to engage really yeah i
can't believe you beat me yeah that's
amazing no one that no one will ever
beat up i know normally my story is like
wow three more months i'm like wow two
weeks so long so how'd you guys meet
uh i was speaking in it's actually one
of the most hilarious stories that
involves russell brand and paul joseph
watson somehow i was speaking in london
that's a weird story i know
doing russell brand's podcast and i'm
supposed to like meet
pjw for a drink really quickly because
we had known each other from the twitter
verse but i didn't know him
and because it was like i didn't really
know him i was like kept pushing him
back as i was working and russell
brandt's podcast went over
and three hours go by and i take my
assistant like just tell peow like you
know we'll do it tomorrow try to meet
him tomorrow and she's like
no there's like a dinner he had his
friends stop at dinner and there's 30 of
the biggest politicians in the uk
waiting for you
george farmer my husband was the one who
wrestled up the dinner and
so i was three hours late to a dinner
that was like done in my honor and
literally saw him knew the second i saw
it it was the weirdest thing
i saw his face and i felt like i knew in
my whole life and
he proposed to me followed me back to
america
i was speaking at um what's the thing at
the end of the year that we did
sas followed me back to sas we were
engaged two weeks later everyone thought
we were completely nuts we had our first
kiss he probably
he apologized um he um proposed on a
plane
going well that is the most romantic
place yeah judge said literally he was
like
facetiming me going down to south to
south africa a proposal plane i said yes
he had our first kiss london heathrow
airport after we were engaged
uh yeah terminal five and we everyone
thought we were nuts
his parents my family best decision i
ever made that we were just meant to be
that's a great story
yeah and by the way if my if my
daughter or son ever came back i'd be
like you're not marrying foreign
are you crazy oh yeah another thing i
definitely learned is that as soon as as
soon as my kids get engaged within 48
hours they're getting married
yeah because the period between
engagement and marriage is like the
worst period in the entire world i loved
it
terrible i loved it she loved it yeah i
loved it it was everything's been such a
walk in the park and i don't know i
think i'm just getting lucky but
my wife has been wonderful yeah my my
wife
she after i asked her to marry me she's
like because the way that it works is i
told her that i loved her
on november 15th she did not say that
she loved me until december 15th
so for a month all of those
conversations were super awkward and
every conversation
i love you okay bye bye
so nice ben um bye right exactly so
sweet of you ben i thank you so for like
a month but it actually turned out that
she was not wrong because as soon as she
said i love you back the first words in
my mouth were okay so we're getting
married
yeah it's like we're done okay done
mission accomplished
and she was like can't we just enjoy
this time like you don't understand i'm
not enjoying this time
it's a very not enjoyable time like now
i'm sitting here we love each other and
i have to like sit here and wonder if
something's getting this is a very not
enjoyable time
i love that you just execute immediately
yeah exactly that's so sweet
last question how is parenthood affected
your political views or career
aspirations
definitely has made everything more
severe where it's like it's not just
it's not just a political debate anymore
right like like we're talking about
transgender russian we can have age we
can say a thousand times why it's wrong
why it's wrong well suddenly when the
people are starting the politics sort of
say okay no we need some laws
now we need to make sure that there's no
like california has proposed a bill
no boy or girl like okay is my child
gonna grow up in this is this even the
same america
that i'm gonna like that i grew up in
like is everything about race my child's
biracial like it just
it's more severe now it kind of is like
no no no
i need to speak up even louder if i
wasn't loud enough before
like and we need to just say this is
right and this is wrong it's not between
right and left anymore it's between
right and wrong and
this is why the danger of people that
say they're too fearful to speak out
just now is not the time to be too
fearful because this is this we don't
recognize this country anymore
if everyone just stays silent so i think
the severity has changed that's 100
right i mean
as soon as you have kids all of a sudden
all the issues where you thought okay
well you know what if you take it down
the road is it really that big a deal
everything becomes incredibly immediate
because you can see that in 20 years
you know i'm 37 and 20 years i'll be 57.
well in 20 years my kids are just going
to be young adults
and so they're just going to be starting
you know their life here what are things
going to be like if things are this bad
now what are things going to be like in
20 years if we continue along this
trajectory yeah so there's that
as far as sort of how it's affected
career i i like to
travel a lot less than i did i was much
easier traveling than than now like i
don't want to be away from my kids
as i was leaving to come here this week
my four-year-old son
turns to me and he goes don't go to
nashville dad don't go to nashville
and i was like that is the that is the
saddest thing i i i like
it tears your heart out you're like why
are you doing this i i did inform him
he's like how am i gonna know when
you're back it's like well
because i was coming back late at night
i'm coming back late at night and he
says how do you how do i know
then you're gonna be back so i'm gonna
come in your room i'm gonna take pants
out of your door and put them on your
head
and he said that's so cute and he said
okay so tonight
ben the dad we don't get this at the
bend this is actually great yeah
silly ben has been the dad my kid my
kids don't know that i'm severe or harsh
in any way
like that's not no they think that i'm
just a giant goofball i'm like i carry
them around and flip them around and
throw them up in the air and all that
kind of stuff so
um it changes it changes you that way
you take yourself a lot less seriously
because kids will absolutely wreck you
yeah i mean like the most honest people
in the world and and also
they're just you realize that you're not
in control of anything because the thing
about kids especially like when they're
babies they're super cute
but then as soon as they you watch when
they hit about it's not terrible twos
it's terrible threes and fours okay once
they hit three they turn in the worst
people that ever live no they're violent
yeah
violent they're they're awful awful
little people yeah they're innocent but
they're terrible small children
and if they ever that's why people like
yeah a child should make up their own
mind about their gender it's like i
wouldn't let my kid
i wouldn't let my kid choose what to eat
for dinner are you insane
are you a crazy person kids are the
worst people
on earth and when you realize that your
job is to try and mold them
and also that you have no control over
them whatsoever beyond a certain point
uh that is uh that is definitely a
different feeling so it definitely
kids humble you they make you take life
a lot more seriously and also
simultaneously not as seriously and they
expand your emotional boundaries what i
always say to folks about having kids is
that
when you're single your your spectrum of
happiness to unhappiness ranges from
about a seven to a zero right so
zero's like you're pretty unhappy and
seven is like you're pretty happy then
you get married and your maximum
happiness is like a ten
and your minimum happiness like a
negative ten because if something
happens that's bad your spouse yeah then
it actually affects you right so before
you might have been to zero but it's
worse when something bad happens
absolutely and then you have kids in all
limits and removed the best things that
ever happened to you are your kids
and by far the worst things that ever
happened to you are things that have to
do with your kids well and so
it's walking a tightrope without any
sort of net we'll always say the
expression it's like you know see
your heart being out of your chest and
walking around and it's all you have no
control over where it's going oh my god
it's all the time yeah like
when they do stuff that's wonderful it's
so wonderful when they do stuff that's
terrible it's
so terrible and then they i'm so excited
i'm just starting this chapter because i
think
family is just the best and i'm like now
that i have a son i just everything he
does and just like he's
looking like he's perfect he's amazing
look at this how dare you define his
gender before he's 18.
he how dare you you're assigning him a
gender candice you're not allowed to do
that yeah exactly how do you know you
have a son
wait until he wait until he turns six
nine wait until he dies he might change
a few times in between ridiculous yeah
boy healthy boy
did you know that every like on this
video creates one additional leftist
tier don't ask me why that's called
science to take advantage of this
amazing opportunity
hit the like button